Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
So, wir sind schwer beladen kurz vorm Salon.
Ja, ein sehr sehr umfangreiches, schweres Buch.
Auch ich habe es als Papierstapel.
Wie kommt es? Bist du jetzt plötzlich Bibliophil geworden?
Ja, so ein bisschen. Ich wollte dann doch nochmal, wenn die Haptik Kilos verspricht, wollte ich auch nochmal die Kilos antun und nein, ich hab ja nichts gegen Haptik. Ich finde nur, es liest sich auch besser, wenn das Buch nicht ein Kilo wiegt. Musste ich auch wieder feststellen. Aber ich dachte mir, da es ein Kilo wiegt, kann ich es mir auch holen.
Da ich ja am Schreibtisch fast immer nur lese, liegt das Buch auf dem Schreibtisch. Und von daher ist das für mich ganz egal, wie schwer ein Buch ist. Aber bevor wir jetzt über das Buch sprechen, mal ganz kurz. Ich sehe dich im Pullover. Das ist selten, sonst sehe ich dich im T-Shirt jetzt im Pullover. Ist das ein kleiner Gruß an Olaf Scholz? Oder wie muss ich das deuten? Über das Pullover-Foto Olaf Scholz steht im Flugzeug, trägt einen Pullover mit Rundhalsausschnitt. Na ja.
Ich fand ja das auf der Treppe noch besser, im T-Shirt.
Genau, ja.
Also ziemlich cool. Nein, du siehst mich in Jacke, die wir gleich ausziehen.
Das ist deine Jacke?
Ja, sie hat vorne noch Reißverschluss, die ist verdeckt gewesen. Und das Besondere an dieser, man muss ja lange suchen, sagen wir es mal so. Ich habe mir ja auch eine Sonnenbrille gekauft, nachdem du mir einen Händler empfohlen hast. Die liegt allerdings jetzt unten auf dem Wohnzimmer, weil ich alle Leute, die durchs Wohnzimmer rauschen, mit meiner Sonnenbrille jetzt immer beeindrucke. Deswegen habe ich sie jetzt nicht hier, um sie dir auch vorzuführen, aber ich zeige sie dir dann Ende des Monats. Es ist ja sehr schwer, Sachen online zu kaufen. Bei Sonnenbrillen dachte ich mir, es geht irgendwie. Ich habe einfach Grün gesucht. Ich bin Fan von Krokodilen und dann habe ich mir so eine Lacoste-Dings geholt. Die passt super, 50 Euro. Gut, ich wollte eh seit Jahren eine haben. Und dann ist mir, als ich gesehen habe, ich habe den Namen vergessen, aber ist auch nicht so wichtig, du hast mir diesen Online-Händler empfohlen und er hat ja tausende Sachen im Angebot. Also wenn man da irgendwas anklickt, steht ja immer gleich 10.000 Auswahlmöglichkeiten. Und dann habe ich gesucht, nachdem ich schon immer längere suche, nämlich Jacken für zu Hause, die man sich kurz drüber wirft, also nicht zwingend zu macht, ohne Kapuze, mit denen man einfach mal auf dem Sofa sitzen kann, ohne dass die ganze Zeit, ah jetzt muss ich das hier nochmal und so. Und jetzt habe ich eine mit einem wirklich tollen Cardigan-Kragen, oder wie man das auch immer nennt, gefunden, die mir einfach sowohl eng zugeht, als auch wenn sie offen ist, nicht so rumschlappert oben. Und ich kann mich anlehnen, ohne dass da irgendwas ist. Ich kann, wenn ich raus zum Müll gehe oder so, schnell die andere Jacke drüber werfen, ohne dass die Kapuze nochmal dazwischen hängt. Also ich habe jetzt auch, ich trage heute kapuzenlose Jacke für zuhause. So wie jeder Kanzler im Grunde.
Was ich ja überhaupt nicht vertragen kann, ist, was über den Kopf zu ziehen. Deswegen sind Pullover für mich eigentlich nichts. Ich habe so zwei, drei Rollkragenpullis, trage die aber äußerst selten und ungern. Ich möchte nichts über den Kopf ziehen.
Also wenn wir dich mit Rollkragen sehen, hat dich jemand gezwungen oder was?
Na ja, es war mal so eine kurze Mode und ich dachte, es sieht eigentlich nicht ganz schlecht aus, aber ich finde es furchtbar, was über den Kopf zu ziehen. Vor allem, weil ich ja ein Frisurproblem dann bekomme. Das heißt, ich muss mir ganz genau überlegen, in welcher Reihenfolge ich was mache. Ich kann nicht die Frisur herrichten und dann den Rollkragenpulli drüber ziehen. Dann muss ich wieder von vorne anfangen. Insofern ist das gar nicht so leicht und dann bin ich mit einem Hemd sehr viel besser bedient. Deswegen trage ich immer Hemd.
Die Plagen des modernen Menschen, über die reden wir ja gleich ausführlich.
Ja, ich möchte nur darauf hinweisen, dass es, um das noch gerade zu Olaf Scholz zu sagen, dass es neben diesen Fotos auch ein Interview gibt von ihm bei CNN. Er war live dort, hat zehn Minuten auf Englisch Stellung genommen zur NATO, Ukraine und so weiter und so fort. Und das ist schon sehr erstaunlich, dass ein Bundeskanzler sich in eine solche Sendung begibt, auf Englisch spricht. Jetzt kann man sagen, na ja, so viele Leute können Englisch, aber hier geht es ja wirklich um Feinheiten. Hier geht es um höchste Diplomatie. Und natürlich ist dieser Auftritt auch sehr bewusst gesetzt, um den Amerikanern ein Signal zu geben und um Putin ein Signal zu geben. Also das ist strategisch gar nicht dumm, das so zu machen. Und das auf Englisch dann zu absolvieren, ist nicht ohne. Ich kenn eine Dolmetscherin, die inzwischen in Rente ist, die am Europäischen Parlament jahrelang war und dann aber auch große Politiker begleitet hat. Und die hat mir mal gesagt, das Allerschlimmste ist, wenn Politiker auf die Idee kommen, in der Sprache des Landes zu sprechen, indem sie sich gerade aufhalten. Denn dann können die großen diplomatischen Fehler passieren. Also sie war immer absolut, auch wenn man gut Englisch kann, sollte man auf den Übersetzer zurückgreifen. Aber wir sehen, Scholz hat sich getraut, das so zu machen. Und das ist schon ein ganz erstaunliches Zeichen. Und ich finde das auch ein bisschen albern, so bei Twitter, wenn nur so getan wird, ja hat er Nord Stream 2 nicht direkt abgesagt und sonst was. Also dass man dieses diplomatische Spiel nicht versteht, dass es da um Interessen und Kräfteverhältnisse geht und dass es jetzt nicht um große Werte geht, die da importiert oder exportiert werden. Das finde ich schon erstaunlich, dass man auch nach dem Afghanistan-Debakel noch immer so naiv jetzt an Außenpolitik herangeht. Also irgendwann müsste man doch auch mal so aus der eigenen Erfahrung heraus eine Lehre gezogen haben und sagen, naja gut, das ging da schon ziemlich schief. Sollen wir jetzt, was sollen wir dann machen? Direkten dritten Weltkrieg oder soll er den bei CNN ausrufen? Oder was sollen wir machen? Also da bin ich doch sehr erstaunt, dass da gar nicht verstanden wird, dass das genau Politik ist, was da jetzt gerade stattfindet.
Ja, wir lesen ja gleich, die ganze These des Buches ist ja, wir sitzen in der Falle und das kann man ja dann in jedem Einzelfall, so wie du es jetzt auch gerade wie gesagt hast, finden. Markus Preiß hat heute Morgen getwittert, Scholz und zwar Hashtag Scholz, Deutschland-Flagge gibt CNN ein Interview auf Englisch. Damit ist natürlich endgültig die Illusion zerstört, er wäre die männliche Angela Merkel. Smiley. Und das stimmt. Und dass Annelena Baerbock auch so rumtourt und überall auf Englisch spricht, ist auch cool und dass Christian Lindner sich nicht getraut. Weshalb wir zum Beispiel von Christian Lindner keine großen, ich habe meinen ersten Auftritt in einer Euro-Gruppe und dann auch noch mal mich mit den Kollegen gezeigt. Lindner steht jetzt ein bisschen solitär da, der er ja auch ist in seiner Funktion. Zumindest wenn er auf europäischer Bühne ist. Und das finde ich hat schon eine ganz gute Haltungsnote verdient. Das mit dem Pullover und dem T-Shirt und das Last Klingball. Noch mal ein Selfie aus dem ICE twittert, wie er auch ein Pullover anhat. Um sich da noch mal an seinen Chef dran zu hängen, finde ich dann auch wieder peinlich, ehrlich gesagt, dass die SPD das immer nicht versteht, dass die Memes von den anderen gemacht werden und dass man das nicht selber machen kann. Aber gut, das ist halt Last Klingball. Damit müssen sie selber klarkommen. So, die Anfänge von Grabber. Es sind, sagen wir es mal so, wenn man ein Buch hat, das inklusive Anhang, ich gucke noch mal nach, jetzt wo ich nachgucken kann, 666 Seiten, na gut 667, aber 666 volle Seiten. Guckt man ja auch noch mal, wie das Gespräch über das Buch so ist. Nun liegt es auf Deutsch erst seit ein paar Tagen vor, auf Englisch schon länger. Ich habe mir die englischen Rezension gar nicht angeguckt. Die deutschen wollte ich angucken, aber die sind ja alle hinter Paywalls. Hast du irgendwas gefunden, was ich zu erwähnen?
Ein bisschen. Ich habe von Max Knirim im SWR erstmal das Interview gehört mit Wengroff und er hat aber auch, Knirim hat auch eine Rezension verfasst, etwa sieben Minuten, die glaube ich sehr gut das Buch zusammenfasst, wenn gleich, ich bin ja, wir werden gleich in die Diskussion einsteigen. Ich glaube, ich war noch nie so gespannt darauf, wie du ein Buch findest im Salon. Also ich bin wirklich hoch gespannt. Jedenfalls ist das eine Rezension, die das Buch sehr fair abbildet. Ich habe noch ein anderes Interview mit einem Anthropologen, glaube ich, gehört dazu, der es auch interessant fand. Lars Weißbrot hat es auch gelobt, aber jetzt nicht überschwinglich, wie mir schien. Aber ich habe jetzt nicht so viel verfolgt dazu. Ich habe nur mitbekommen, es ist ein Buch, das sehr stark rezipiert wird, das sehr weit oben sein wird auf den Bestsellerlisten, was ja erstmal sehr verwunderlich ist bei einem Buch, das diesen Umfang hat und das sagt, wir denken mal Anthropologie und Archäologie zusammen und erklären eine neue Geschichte. Darum geht es ja, das ist schon ganz erstaunlich. Es könnte aber damit zusammenhängen, dass man den Titel doch sehr klug gewählt hat. Nämlich die Untertitel, die gleichen sich ja so in den vergangenen Jahren doch sehr. Also hier haben wir den Untertitel Eine neue Geschichte der Menschheit. Und es gibt aus den letzten zwei, drei Jahren etwa zehn Bücher, die entweder eine neue Geschichte oder eine andere Geschichte der Menschheit erzählen. Steven Pinker, Rutger Pregmann und und und. Das ist wohl etwas, was man machen muss, wenn man einen Bestseller schreiben will. Also du kannst mal überlegen. Opa Kalypse, eine andere Geschichte der Menschheit. Vielleicht wir jetzt auch, wenn wir noch mal eine neue Auflage nehmen. Influencer, eine neue Geschichte der Menschheit. Man weiß es nicht.
Es hat gewisse Konjunktur jetzt die, und da gibt es ja die auch ein bisschen amüsant geschriebene Dissertation von Franos Retschky oder so heißt er, über die Diagnose-Gesellschaft. Alle wollen noch mal die große Diagnose abgeben. Und was ist eigentlich die große Diagnose? Manchmal, also klar, man kann jetzt so zoologisch mal drüber fliegen und das alles so albern und absurd finden. Manchmal stimmt es aber. Also manchmal liegt man wirklich in eine neue Geschichte der Menschheit vor. Das zumindest würde ich sagen, finden wir hier. Um dich und die Hörer weiter anzuteasen, was ich jetzt von dem Buch halte, ich werde es natürlich einrahmen in einen Kontext zweier Werke, die noch umfangreicher sind. Das eine ist natürlich das Handbuch Geschichte des politischen Denkens, um das sich Surgram bemüht hat. Manfred Brocke hat es herausgegeben. Da werden ja alle mal genannt. Also da geht es los mit Platon 385 vor Christus. Und es endet dann mit, was weiß ich, Ottfried Höfer, keine Ahnung, wer das ist.
Ja, Kantvorrat.
1999. Dazwischen kommen aber alle vor, die irgendwie eine Rolle spielen. Und zu den Autoren, die Anmerkungen beginnt dann auf Seite 823. Also das ist sozusagen das, wovon man sich wegbewegt mit Anfänge. Wenn man jetzt so ein Pendel macht, die Geschichte des politischen Denkens, dann schlägt das Pendel so, das Buch wird geschrieben. Und wo will es eigentlich hin pendeln? Wo will es uns hinführen? Und da ist natürlich Luhmann, die Gesellschaft der Gesellschaft.
Wer hätte das gedacht?
Wer hätte es gedacht? Selten erwähnt, auch von mir im Podcast. Aber hier muss man es, glaube ich, mal anbringen. Und das sind natürlich zwei Bände, die hinauslaufen auf 1000, irgendwas 100 Seiten. Und zwar klein geschrieben. Also das ist ja nun das Buch der Bücher.
Obwohl ich ja glaube, dass Länge gar nicht unbedingt das Problem ist. Ich werde auch gleich im Salon mal erzählen, dass ich erhebliche Lektüre-Probleme hatte mit diesem Buch. Also jetzt nicht, dass ich sage, die Passagen haben mir nicht gefallen oder dies und das, sondern dass ich wirklich mich fragte, wie mache ich denn jetzt da eigentlich weiter? Und das geschieht relativ selten bei mir. Also auch das eine neue Erfahrung. Und ich habe mich dann mal kurz ins Akustische geflüchtet, um dann wieder zurück zum Buch zu kehren. Ich werde davon berichten. Also es wird eine Diskussion sein, die wahrscheinlich nicht ganz kurz ist. Aber wir haben auch noch Texte, die wir vorstellen. Ich will nur auf einen hier schon mal hinweisen, der wichtig sein wird, den ich auch ein bisschen länger vorstellen möchte. Ein Text, der im Jacobin erschienen ist. Und da geht es darum, dass wir heute nicht mehr in postpolitischen, sondern in hyperpolitischen Zeiten leben. Und was das bedeutet, das müssen wir mal diskutieren. Und dann habe ich noch kleinere Texte und Hinweise dabei.
Das klingt gut. Man tabt ja immer so in die Falle, man liest so ein großes Buch. Und danach liest man auch die anderen Texte nur noch im Kontext dieses Buches. So geht es mir heute bei den weiteren vier Texten. Zum einen, wir haben alle davon gehört, dass das Autofahren 5000 Euro kostet, vergesellschaftete Kosten. Wir gucken noch mal rein, wie das genau aufgeschlüsselt ist und was diese Studie sagt. Außerdem stellen die Verfassungsrechtler fest. Was ist mit den Querdenkern? Die sind alle einsam. Also das kann man natürlich auch noch mal schön in den Kontext des Grebber Anfängebuchs setzen. Dann, weil Jahrestag war, 28. Januar, peak GameStop. Es ist ja ein Buch erschienen, wir lesen kurz einen Text über dieses Buch, das erschienen ist. Es ist doch eine ganz interessante These drin. Und das Homeoffice hat es sich jetzt bewährt. Sind die Leute produktiver und gleich glücklicher oder unproduktiver und unglücklicher? Oder kann man so eine marktwirtschaftliche? Es lohnt sich irgendwie, die Leute sind zwar unglücklicher, aber produktiver. Da gibt es eine ganz große Studie, die durch Zufall an der Uni Leipzig Ende 2019 begann. Also als noch gar kein Homeoffice war. Wegen der Ansicht vier Sachen, die man hier nochmal in den Kontext der moderne unseres Lebens einfügen kann. Gut, dann verabschieden wir uns von allen und sagen herzlich willkommen gleich an alle Salon-Mitglieder. Wir lesen jetzt 10.000 Jahre Grebber auf 600 Seiten. Oder wie auch immer, sind noch ein paar mehr Jahre, glaub ich sogar.